what is retrieval augmented generation
also known as RG or grounding R is a new
AI framework that combines large
language models with external knowledge
bases to improve the accuracy of model
response imagine you have a Wikipedia
page on T Swift that you like all your
answers to gr it on it's your source of
Truth RG retrieves information through
the Wikipedia API using tax beding
combine Dural prompt with retrieve
contacts send it to the LM to generate
the final output for example1 as LM how
many record had Terra Swift sold
globally if the isn't tra on the most
recent data the model give you a wrong
response by using Wikipedia API as my
knowledge base I can secure the correct
response because it's grounded on the
given knowledge base is like a cheat
sheet for the ads check out the RG blog
post yourself and share the comments
down below